the very day that this video airs I will
be going along with my wife to my 35th
High School reunion it won't be at the
high school but just so you know what
high school we're talking about Catholic
Memorial High School in Waukesha and I
haven't gone to any of the reunions
prior to this so it'll be kind of
interesting to see what happens and it
reminded me of something that I think
um I found humorous and also surprising
at the time and I think you might also
find both humorous and surprising given
you know what you know about me as this
52 year old guy who shoots videos and
talks about philosophy and all of that
so graduation right back in I think it
must have been June of 1988 I think we
got out in in June
big production right by that time I was
actually so ready to be done with high
school and I was already you know
working uh what what was going to be not
just a summer job but a job for a while
and my plans were not to go on to
college but rather to go into the army
and I'll tell you a little bit about
that in just a minute so you know I
didn't have the kind of stress that a
lot of my fellow students were carrying
with them of oh I'm going to go off to
college and uh oh it's you know more
education or I was pretty much done
other than the training that I would get
in the army down the line and
um something really funny happened
during the graduation ceremony so if if
you're not familiar with American
graduation ceremonies because I do have
a sort of an international uh viewership
they're all kind of the same there's
people who give like a speech it's very
aspirational they're you know sometimes
a local notable or somebody who went to
the school and you're wearing these caps
and gowns they're they're usually the
school colors so at Catholic Memorial
they're all wearing you know kind of a
bluish gown and then you've got the the
mortar caps on top and sometimes people
embellish them these days with like you
know a stole or a pin or something like
that back then we didn't do that
everybody basically wore the same thing
um sometimes people will wear
um like you know a dress or a suit or
something kind of fancy or formal
underneath it there's a little bit of a
funny thing before that we had to do
this uh practice uh before it and I
actually just wore a speedo underneath
mine because I knew that the whole thing
was was zipped up and nobody could tell
anything and I knew it was going to be
hot as hell the day that we we actually
had to do the rehearsal before we did
the actual thing at night in in the
auditorium
so anyway you know I'm Sadler so my name
comes kind of late in the game you start
out with the A's and then you get to do
the B's and the C's and everybody walks
across the stage and there's the
principal and certain other teachers and
they shake your hand and they give you
this this thing that's got your diploma
inside hopefully right you don't
actually know until you open it up and
then you get off the stage and you know
your family like cheers and stuff like
that and then they had Awards and I
don't remember what any of the other
awards were
um I should mention too that usually
there's like a valedictorian this is the
person who's got the best grades and
they get to give a speech as well blah
blah blah you know I mean what would
they possibly know at that age that
could be you know interesting or helpful
and I don't even remember who our
valedictorian was quite frankly because
I was just kind of like coasting through
it you know my friends were graduate
waiting with me we're gonna go to
parties after that and you know my I
know my mom and sister were there and
maybe some of my other family members so
anyway you know you do the graduation
thing walk across the stage shake the
hands with everybody I think people took
some pictures or something like that and
then you go back to your your seats
and they have this award and that award
and this person's going up to get that
award and then I hear my name called
you know and uh they said we had we have
an award for Gregory Sadler and I was
thinking what could that possibly be I
mean I've kind of been screwing around
like you know the last couple years here
I was I'll tell you more about this why
it was so surprising for me let me just
jump to what the award was
so
I get up there on the stage and they say
for succeeding despite the odds and they
hand me a a sort of a you know a wooden
thing that you can put on the wall a
plaque right and I'm looked down and it
does it says that for succeeding despite
the odds I'm not sure what happened to
that I I lost it somewhere along the
line and it comes with an envelope as
well because
um it's a scholarship right
a scholarship check from some local law
firm uh and you know it was for somebody
who was you know
suffered some adversity or was kind of a
a screw-up not living up to their
potential or maybe they were living up
to their potential and they succeeded
whatever success was and I guess success
was I actually graduated
so you know I get this and I'm like
it's kind of a backhanded compliment
isn't it you know
um nobody else is getting this they all
succeeded but I succeeded despite the
the odds
and I don't know who voted on it right
it must have been some of our teachers
or you know the principal or somebody
like that so I take it and I go back to
my seat and then later on you know after
we're all sort of like released and I go
go and you know I'm with my my mom and
my sister and I don't remember who else
maybe maybe one of her boyfriends maybe
it was Fran at that time uh they're like
what what was that about and I I'm like
I don't I don't know you know and so we
look at it and there's a check for 700
in there and that was a lot of money
back then
um
you know if you think about the costs of
things now 700 bucks wouldn't be that
much at this point in time but just to
give you like an idea
um so I began paying rent that summer uh
because uh the Social Security survivors
benefits
um for you know my dad had died when I
was 11. my mom got survivor benefits for
both me and my sister while we were
still in school so even though I wasn't
18 as soon as high school ends they're
cut off right so my mom was like hey I
need you to pay some rent you know I
think three hundred dollars would be
fair and and that was actually way more
than fair considering how much I ate
back then
um and so
um
you know that gives you an idea can you
rent some place for 300 now no but I
mean this would have been like two
months worth of living expenses for me
so
um
the intention
of the award was that it would be used
you know for school expenses that I
would be going off to college and
um you know maybe I'd buy books with it
or it would it would be like Furnishings
for the room or something like like that
right
um but I didn't spend it on that what
did I spend it on well I just happened
to be enrolled
in a Karate Dojo in downtown Waukesha
and I wanted to learn karate well uh it
was with uh Neil stolzmark was the
Sensei back then he might still be for
all I know and uh it was showing her
karate right and so
um given that I had that money I was
like well
I was going to be paying for karate uh
classes and you know buying the
equipment and stuff that I needed with
the job that I have at Kentucky Fried
Chicken there's a whole other story I
could tell about that I think I may have
talked about that in a video before
under crappy jobs that I've had
uh but now I've got enough money to like
buy six months of tuition right off the
bat you know and so I went in and uh you
know first I I I had to open up a bank
account so I go to the local bank I
actually could just walk there and
um you know put the check in there had a
checking account uh next day went down
to the karate studio met with sensing
and uh wrote them a check and now there
was still some money left in there I
guess what I've been doing previously
was just like going to my family's bank
and when I'd get a paycheck from work
I'd just cash the whole damn thing and
turn it into to bills and and coins
right
um I didn't have a checking account
until that that point in time so my mom
was not thrilled with this
and she insisted that I write a letter
to the law firm sort of you know
thanking them which a good thing and
then
um slash apologizing explaining
why the money was not going to go to any
sort of Institute of higher education
but rather to
studying karate which I was doing by the
way you know I was working uh at night
for I ended up quitting Kentucky Fried
and starting to work at a Ponderosa
Steakhouse
um you know the the evening shift and I
could work out in the day and so I was
in that Dojo most days anywhere from
like two to four hours a day you know I
actually progressed very very quickly
um and you know I was so we're talking
about a time from June of
1998 to February of 1999 when I actually
entered the the Army and then went off
to basic training
um so that's what I spent the money on
and I and I wrote this letter I never
actually heard back from the law firm
and I'm kind of happy I didn't because
you know I didn't imagine that they
would be particularly thrilled about me
doing this particularly since you know
it was sort of like a typical
Greg the burnout metal guy kind of thing
to do you know so why did I get an award
for succeeding despite the ads
well I was kind of a screw-up in high
school you know I I I was very smart you
know I tested well and I came in and you
know I came in in 1984 and that um
summer I had begun lifting weights I was
listening to some heavy metal bands
before that but you know I discovered
iron maiden and rat and Motley Crew and
you know Twisted Sister and all you know
eventually by the end of the summer
Judas Priest and Black Sabbath and all
these bands and I was like getting into
it and I knew other people who were into
it through my my mom was in Parents
Without Partners and this was like a a
club for people who were either widowed
or divorced single parents who wanted to
meet other single parents date them
sometimes it was just hookups and we'd
often go on like camping trips and you
know canoe doing and all sorts of things
and so it was a it was a way for like
the parents to get to hang out with
other people who were going through the
same thing as them and we kids we would
have a great time you know at least
those of us who are socially inclined
and those in that group who are into
heavy metal because there was this guy
Jerry who was like a year older than me
and you know he knew all sorts of bands
and then there were the Ron girls one of
whom was younger than me one who was who
is uh the same age as me and Jerry knew
them and there were a couple other
people that all we all kind of hung out
in it and there were other kids in the
neighborhood who were getting into to
metal as well so you know we'd like
skateboard around and listen to AC DC or
kiss or Metallica later on
um and and just you know get into
trouble and meanwhile I'm entering High
School
so I get to high school and I'm already
growing my hair for me at that time kind
of long it's not really like the length
that it is now but it was longish in the
80s enough to draw attention you know
and I'm I'm wearing stuff that's
pretty tame now but you know considered
kind of like burnout Garb back then and
then I get in with a bunch of other kids
who are into this sort of stuff
including the older kids who
um I meet in part because I want a fence
I want to you know learn to fight with
swords I'd always wanted to be a sword
fighter since I saw like the Three
Musketeers when I was a kid and so this
is an opportunity to do that turns out
they were the burnouts you know the kids
who wear the leather jackets listen to
heavy metal do crimes you know some of
them were super into drugs and drinking
and and stuff like that and
um so anyway I ran with kind of a rough
older crowd and you know got into
trouble here and there I carried around
uh you know butterfly knife and we would
get in fights with the jocks and they'd
beat us up and we'd beat them up and you
know we'd have like some somebody would
have a boom box in school and we'd be
playing you know Ozzy Osborne or Dio or
stuff like that in the Halls during
during the breaks so it was like a whole
thing right it was it was uh I won't say
I won't go so far as to call it a
lifestyle but it was definitely kind of
a commitment and along with that went um
you know not really taking academics
that seriously and I I wasn't inclined
to take academic seriously when I was in
high school I wanted to have fun and
figure out who I was and you know listen
to this cool music and and do do things
right I will say that that I did do very
well in gym class
I really liked Jim that has to do in
part with who the coach was who I've
talked about elsewhere Chuck bulva uh
you know I did fencing I ran track so I
wasn't like a total burnout but you know
I also kind of I screwed up a good bit
and didn't take my other classes
seriously and the literature and English
classes I'd read whatever I wanted to
read and then just you know I didn't pay
much attention to what the assignments
were I did really like history you know
but I didn't always like my history
teachers
math I took the minimal amount that I
needed to like
finish up you know as far as the state
was concerned so I got to Algebra 2 and
trig and just quit doing math funny
because I became a math major in college
later on
and
um
you know I actually took a lot of art
classes believe it or not I took
painting and jewelry and Ceramics and it
was in part because that's what the
burnouts were doing they would they
would take art classes some of them and
anyway long story short I was I was a
screw-up you know I would sleep in class
my last two years I was really you know
screwing around a lot as I became what
they call an upperclassman
and you know I also got into a lot of
trouble
um there was there was a summer where I
got arrested I'd been getting in fights
and stuff like that and I wound up in a
juvenile detention center for quite a
while they did like some psych tests on
me and
um I wound up in a psychiatric hospital
for for a while as I as I got in there I
you know the people that were in there
that was really a harrowing experience
because they were like yeah these tests
these people did them wrong the county
people you don't have the problems that
they say that you do but we're going to
keep you in here anyway
and I saw some people who were really
really really messed up and that was
very perspective providing for me I was
like you know I better get my my crap
together not academically but you know
in terms of like figuring out my life
problems and you know I did have some
some issues I was um
getting in fights a lot because I think
you know my dad having died I never
really had processed that you know I'd
been told like at the funeral I had
these people coming up to me who were
his friends saying you're the man of the
house now I was like 11 right at the
time so that's a terrible thing to to
tell people when they're that age it's
not helpful at all and one thing you
don't learn when you have when you don't
have a good male role model around is
like when you know guys mess with each
other so should you pop somebody in the
face or should you fight with them or
threaten them or should you take things
as a joke right and it's it's easier to
learn that stuff when you have somebody
I mean if my dad had lived
he would have been very helpful with all
that sort of stuff so I didn't know how
to manage all of these things belonging
aggression fear
um you know wanting to figure out how
dating worked and all that kind of stuff
and and it took a toll on me but um I
also got to see kids who were really in
terrible situations
the stuff that happened to me wasn't
that bad but it it you know it it kind
of did some damage there were other kids
who had it way way worse and so anyway
I get out I get back to school you know
senior year is going on
um and you know they actually had like a
support group for kids who'd had losses
and it was kind of interesting too we
had a senior Retreat and I was I got put
on the committee somehow one of the
teachers uh wanted me to do that it was
it was a chance for me to interact with
the kids who weren't in my group and the
senior retreat was you know pretty uh
pretty interesting experience you know
you got to find out like what other kids
who you thought had it all together were
actually going through and a lot of them
had some serious issues as well and
because I had worked through my stuff I
could be kind of a leader and be a
compassionate ear
weirdly enough right uh for helping out
these these other people so who knows I
don't know who put me up for the award
but they felt that I had succeeded and
you know making it through high school I
suppose was a sort of success
um
I immediately you know went into this
thing of just working and studying
karate and getting drunk with my friends
on the weekends and doing a lot of like
uh we weren't supposed to be doing you
know full contact stuff but we would do
it anyway our sense if he found out he
would have kicked us out of the dojo uh
you know we'd beat the crap out of each
other and all that and then I went in
the Army and and you know the idea was
that
um I was either going to be a lifer or a
friend of mine his uncle had actually
been a mercenary and he had contacts and
it was the you know late 80s so that's
that's what I had planned to do very
unrealistic sort of Life ideas but you
know that's that's where I was at the
time
so anyway fast forward now 35 years I
haven't seen any of these people with a
few exceptions
um since then
and it will be very interesting to see
what they look like what you know many
of them I don't I know the names but I
can't place them with faces and some of
them I don't even recognize the names
so it'll be interesting to see what all
of us have turned into
so far down the line you know
lifetimes ago I mean 35 years so I was
17 when I graduated from high school
more than double that amount of time has
passed now
right
so anyway that's uh you know we'll see
what happens with with that if if
interesting things happen at the reunion
maybe I'll do another video
but I just wanted to bring up that funny
award uh succeeding despite the odds
that I got at my high school graduation